you look beautiful well thank you how
are you feeling though your oldest is
getting married she's my baby i am
it just really started hitting me
yesterday at the rehearsal and i didn't
sleep last night and i i woke up and the
sun was setting and i just said my
prayers i'm just
so so
so happy rick and i are
thrilled beyond words and we just wish
that our parents could be here
to celebrate but there will be pictures
of them on the altar you guys have all
these incredible traditions it sounds
like paris spent the night here with you
last night as part of it i heard she
snuck out though so she snuck out you
know she's a gate climber
you know what that's the paris we know
and love isn't it
so what do you do like last night ahead
of the wedding what are some of those
hilton family traditions to prepare we
just all had dinner we called in and had
you know food and we were doing seating
until
1 30 this morning and um
just just very excited yeah
who's gonna be more emotional today the
big day you or rick
i don't know you know until i'm there
i cry at a stranger's wedding so i can
walk by a church and hear the bells and
uh
i don't know okay
well it's good i mean we're all so
excited and paris has brought everybody
on this journey what about carter makes
him the one
he is so kind he treats her
like
just a lady he's just wonderful he's
upbeat they have a lot of fun together
they really enjoy each other's company
and
they are in love and
you know being in lockdown for
almost two years this november 25th
that's a long time being together
24 7. so she's been working she's been
working at home so so it sounds like we
have faith in this relationship they
know each other inside and out yes
she's waited so she's been very
responsible um when it comes down to
really
walking down the aisle and we have about
what 45 minutes to an hour so
we'll all be just like
yes
just walk just go
give me some of the numbers how many
days have you been setting up for the
big event so far
about a week about a week okay how many
guests
um i think
250. how many different dresses will we
see paris in i believe three okay i love
it how do you think she's feeling is she
nervous emotional as she's waited for
this big day i talked to her this
morning and it was interesting she was
getting involved with the seating and
changing things so if you don't like
your seat
uh paris
is the one that did the seating sounds
like a perfectionist she's i know she's
a hard worker so she's down to the wire
on the details she is down to the wire
it was so funny we were at mark's garden
uh looking at the flowers then we added
more
and it was cute to see that she
was really getting into now what kind of
rose is that oh i like that we changed a
lot last minute how does it feel to see
her finding true love and having this
moment
it's it's so important and to be able to
do both is fabulous yeah and but she's
ready to settle down
and be married and have a partner and
start a family as soon as they're able
to
is that a top priority yes are you ready
for that yes
more grand babies in the house i'm more
than ready
do you know how many kids they want to
have
probably three or four okay i love it
fill up the house yes um so
i know you can't give me the exact
numbers but what adjectives would you
use to describe
paris hilton's wedding budget
um
you know it's it's beautiful it's
tasteful
it is
romantic
it is graceful it is
it's just beautiful it really really is
paris with touches of pink not too much
so you have moet involved in a special
cocktail for the day right tell us about
it yes it's the cotton candy pink cotton
candy with the champagne and this is
mine mob mother of the bride
and rick was so cute he doesn't drink
champagne but he said
where's mine
so we have to get a fob
right
we need a fob and i've been asked a lot
of questions in the last two days okay
like where's this where's the baby's
shoes where are the little this where's
the bridesmaids guess what i say
idk
that's and now speaking you know
everybody says how i speak in code
now i'm just giving initials okay so you
have to learn the new language so what
does idk mean i don't know
i just wanted to make sure because we
had some fun times with hunky dory and
who is hunky dory me
so hunky dory is about to go have her
daughter get married hunky is very
excited she has got to go put her dress
on and i'm going to be walking into the
cocktail
like this so
oh and this is hunky dory style this is
the cocktail hour outfit yes no this is
my robe
okay well um we got we do have to ask
you um of course we all want to see you
on real housewives of beverly hills
again so will we
you know i don't know what i'm doing
tomorrow i could be skiing off
mount everest i don't right now i'm just
like concentrating on the wedding okay
and then we are uh just to clear it up i
am not going on the honeymoon we are
taking a family trip on this sunday for
a week and then they go off on their
honeymoon nikki is uh maid of honor yes
she is what is going to be i call her
the first lady at the wedding oh i love
that what does that make you though i'm
just the mother of the bride okay
um what is going to be your favorite
part of today today my sisters kim and
kyle will both be there and all of their
families
and
friends have come in from all over the
world
from everywhere so just to be in a room
with all the people that we love that
are just so excited
um
and then there's some entertainment and
i don't know it's a surprise so